The blue whale lives in the sea.
Does anything else live in the sea?
The hungry shark hunts in the sea.
Does anything else hunt in the sea?
The giant sea turtle floats in the sea.
Does anything else float in the sea?
Schools of fish swim in the sea.
Does anything else swim in the sea?
The eight-armed octopus moves in the sea.
Does anything else move in the sea?
The barking seal glides in the sea.
Does anything else glide in the sea?
Crabs and lobsters crawl in the sea.
Does anything else crawl in the sea?
Yes, yes. Lots of things live in the sea.
Can you name more swimming sea things?
Where does the blue whale live?
The blue whale lives in the sea.
Does the hungry shark live in the sea, too?
Yes, it does.
Does the big hungry bear also live in the sea?
No, it doesn't. It lives in the mountains.